Oh still miss no okay what if we not
what I meant to do okay through the tree
worked through the tree what did it
where did it go where is it do called
find a cliff are you kidding
Museum how much yes I do
they're just in my bank account it's
your you own this service how do you not
know what's in my bank account okay I
want to put it on the note not what I
want it definitely want you to put it on
the edge try again that's more like it
okay oh great great yeah that's I'm so
happy that this is happening to me
yes beautiful yes yes okay it got rid of
my bamboo
it got rid of to lots of bamboo no yep
can't do anything when someone's trying
to come to your Island and only one
person can come at a time
brilliant multiplayer also half the time
it like fails out of there's a
connection issue it's good stuff I love
it it's such a fan do I have to like I
think that that was wrong surely that
was wrong but who I can't see I can't
tell I think I put that square in the
wrong place first quit you know what I
wanted to do yep definitely one back can
you imagine if you could select a square
and when you go mate come on nope okay
bit just try it hit Oh still not okay
maybe just too close who knew the
eyebrows took a while and also I'm not
perfect but for some reason even though
they look dark brown in the customizer
like if I pull it up like they look doc
here but on my face they look orange
yeah so I have to move this stupid house
here because two of my villages have
basically identical houses and they
happen to spawn next to each other which
naturally I have no control over so I
moved this here so that I can then move
it back to a different plot of land and
I have to move both houses which cost me
like $50,000 each and takes a day each
back excuse me excuse me did you move
please excuse me I'm trying to move the
Beehive here if you could just skip
thank you
I just clipped on some of the many
things just again on every it's just so
much clipping hate that you can't move
the camera as well why do they make a
game where you can't control the camera
in 2020 I have you done that I want two
of these if only sometimes I want more
than two of something and it takes an
entire goddamn lifetime yeah let's do it
again right now see the fact that you
can't do multiple of this at the same
time this game is maybe not good and we
may be collectively as a society need to
acknowledge that nope I'm trying to
rotate it no other way other way
No rotate it not push rotate that's how
I wanted it okay yeah can you imagine we
could put bridges above grounds like I
know that these would have to be closer
together but that would look really
pretty
honestly I love this game it is
extremely wholesome and I've put so much
time into it it's just garbage at the
same time I mean why can't it be both